what's the number one secret to
abundance actually there are two uh that
are absolutely important number one is
your only identity and only relationship
is that with the infinite anytime
there's self-importance it's the same
thing is self-c concern that leads to
what we call scarcity Consciousness so
self-importance
and ego identity and contraction and
scarcity all go together have
relationship only with your infinite
self the infinite self is infinitely
abundant it's the source of all
experiences in every sensient being in
the totality of existence that we know
of hey it's s Carl Michael and I make
these videos because I need them for me
because I want to wake up every day and
watch a video that puts me in a mindset
to believe in myself more and go off and
accomplish amazing things and attack the
day and I hope that this video does that
for you as well so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only deepo Chopra
enjoy if our source is infinite then if
that source is pure Consciousness then
we are that source so the only only only
way to identify yourself is your
relationship with the infinite and if
your relationship is in the infinite
then you know in every seed the promise
of thousands of forests
in every life form the expression of
infinity in that life forms
experiences as humans we develop false
identities we call them ego identities
contracted identities conditioned mind
identities and as long as we are
contracted in that scarcity there's no
generosity of spirit so generosity of
spirit is infinite infinite the source
of creativity is infinite as I've said
before for every thought infinite more
thoughts for every emotion infinite more
emotion for every idea infinite more for
every little piece that you give
connection with generosity of spirit it
returns
multiplied multiplied it's like throwing
seeds more you uh Express generosity of
spirit the more it multiplies the second
secret and this is equally important is
every day ask yourself what am I
grateful for not withstanding what is
happening in your life or the stock
market or your job or whatever what am I
grateful for will open the door to
abundance Consciousness to this source
which is generosity of spirit which is
infinite don't get stuck in
melodrama this whole world is full of
drama drama everything is that sells is
drama news is not news anymore it's
opinion and drama and all the violence
in the world is drama and you know you
read about drama shooting killing incest
all crazy stuff and we are addicted to
trauma actually and then we complain
about it does this mean we have we
should like you know I'm thinking about
my relationship with technology and
social media and news feeds and stuff
well technology is neutral you know it's
inescapable it's p part of a revolution
if you don't adapt to technology you'll
become extinct also so it's part of our
Evolution how do we use technology you
know in my field AI machine
learning Precision diagnosis and even
intervention I believe technology is is
a great
gift but again technology can destroy
the world
too this is what it means to be human
humans are a very interesting species
our Fall From Grace is exactly what you
know mythical Traditions tell us the
knowledge of Good and Evil we ate the
fruit so often people come to me and the
reason that they're seeking and
listening is they want to know that
there's a purpose of their
life what do you think that that
is purpose ultimate purpose in life is
to know who you are that's it nobody
knows who they are say are you a body
well which one fertiliz eggs Z go which
one you don't have a body it's an
activity perceptual activity then some
people say I'm my mind so which one you
know you had a different mind when you
were a teenager others say I my
personality well hopefully that is
evolving unless you want to run unless
you want to run for president then you
can inre your personality at 8 years of
emotional
development so who are you this is the
most important question who you are is
the infinite pretending to be a person
and that is the most joyest thing that
can be experienced when you really look
at the credit it is improved nutrition
and sanitation so people were dying of
malnutrition which made them more
susceptible to infections and other
disorders and then sanitation and
vaccination that's how we it's not
antibiotics let's say it's not
Pharmaceuticals it's still conditions of
living know better hygiene better
nutrition but now the the increment to
that is understanding what causes
accelerated aging lack of sleep stress
unhealthy emotions like hostility and
anger and resentments and guilt and
shame and depression and anxiety lack of
Mind Body coordination that's where the
yoga and the breathing techniques come
in um poor nutrition right now most of
our
food that comes um to us at home is
manufactured refined processed contains
chemicals contains antibiotics contains
steroids because animals are fed that
and even you know there are pesticides
in the ground which are petroleum
products how does that cause accelerated
aging it causes inflammation of
something called the microbiome which is
the genes that are in your gut which are
microbial genes so 99% of the genetic
information in your body right now is
not human you only have 1% of the genes
in your body are from your parents 99%
of the genes in your body right now are
microbial you're a few human cells I'm a
mutant I'm like an X-Man
is you a few human cells hanging on to a
bacterial Colony so when you put food in
your mouth the first thing that they
encount the food encounters is these
bacterial genes and if your food is
inflamed then the bacterial genes get
inflamed causes inflammation in the body
you get metabolites that are called cyto
there's lots of complexity between the
human genome the microbiome and
lifestyle but knowing this we can extend
our AG also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there we have to actually see why we
failed in the past and that is because
idealism without action is useless you
know they say that love without action
is irrelevant and action without love is
meaningless but when you have Love In
Action and love for the greater good
then things can happen you have to have
experience love in order to create love
and then you bring into action it starts
with empathy which is feeling what
others are feeling compassion which is
the desire to alleviate suffering and if
you have that then that is the basis of
all love but then love has to move into
action as well really what are the
benefits that you have seen and how do
you practice meditation in your life so
you know I'm now as I told you 7 six
I've been
meditating for close to 45 years wow
every day I also do yoga every day and
there are many types of meditation and
you have something called inquiry
self-reflection mindfulness of breath of
emotions of Mind of mental space of
physical world um but the eight limbs of
yoga cover everything and that's my new
book the new book The Light living in
the light right yeah yoga for
selfrealization so eight limbs of yoga
first is social intelligence second is
emotional intelligence third is the Yoga
practices fourth is breathing techniques
hundreds of them fifth is withdrawal of
the senses learning how to control your
autonomic nervous system sixth is
focused intention
attention that seventh is meditation and
eighth is Transcendence so that's the
complete practice this people said don't
have time those who don't have time need
it more than what's something people can
do daily that helps them access their
true identity their self going beyond
the ego and the mind and the body I
think the basic of it is to still the
mind as much as
possible and just become a Silent
Witness um to that which is happening on
the screen of your Consciousness MH so
if you to um close your eyes and take a
few deep
breaths and then um you know I usually
start with a little reflection Who Am I
who wants to know the answer what is it
that wants to know the answer to the
question who am I uh what is my
purpose uh what do I want for me and the
world what am I grateful for that's how
I start then I go into a little bit of
breathing and and then Mantra meditation
and then what I do is I witness what's
happening on the screen of my
Consciousness just becoming aware and
sooner or later you realize that what's
happening on the screen of Consciousness
is not who you are you're the one who's
watching that and then what's happening
on the screen of your Consciousness
ultimately leads to deep insights about
mind and body and the physical world
which actually doesn't really exist but
we can get into that when we talk about
metahuman but I think if people just ask
these four questions every day before
they start their day even without a
prolonged meditation uh process who am I
what do I want what's my purpose what am
I grateful for suddenly the windows to
the bigger reality starts start to open
absolutely this is such a beautiful
point that deepak's making right now for
everyone listening and watching it's
just such a simple way of starting to
transcend the noise and the Clutter that
we feel every morning when we wake up
and the first thing we do is look at our
phones all you have to do is just switch
that habit for asking yourself these
questions and you don't need to know the
answers because you know there are no
fixed answers these answers keep
changing all you have to do is live the
questions and then life keeps moving you
into answers that you need at that
moment in your life and it all happens
spontaneously synchronistically such a
great Point what is the Quantum
vacuum again um it's part of something
called Quantum field theories the
quantum vacuum is the source of all the
energy and matter in the universe all of
it all the source of energy and matter
in the universe comes from the quantum
vacuum which is
brimming with this activity that is
referred to as virtual particles in that
you can't can't see them but through
various
Technologies you can be sure that they
exist they exist not as real particles
but as the
potential for what we call real
particles okay so the quantum vacuum is
the source of virtual
energy and virtual
particles that ultimately become real
energy
and real
particles and these real
particles ultimately end up being atoms
molecules matter rocks
trees uh clouds rainbows Stars
galaxies your own physical body but also
other biological organisms rabbits
elephants dolphins whales anything you
can think of
any entity you can think of as physical
has its
source
in this Quantum
vacuum now I've asked a lot of my
physicist friends friends is this thing
that we call Quantum vacuum which
obviously is not how we usually think of
matter and
energy is this in space and time
I I asked my physicist
friends and you can go look up Wikipedia
or you can go look up Google or any
other source in the
internet and you can ask this question
you know is the Quantum vacuum in
SpaceTime and you'll see that you'll get
lots of answers that are ambiguous some
people say yes some people say
no but the quantum vacuum can cannot be
seen okay just know that the quantum
vacuum is not something that you can
know through your
senses it's a hypothetical mathematical
construct for the fact that the entire
universe has a
source in what we as normal human beings
even without a background of science we
would say the source is IM
material in the sense that there's
nothing that we can
identify as a material
object it is an
emptiness it's a
void it's the potential for Energy
Information
matter and ultimately everything that we
call physical including your own body
take some time every day to be
unoccupied even spiritual Pursuit is an
occupation so take a little bit of you
know what's I think it was Kafka or
somebody who said all of human problem
Humanity's problems come from our
inability to sit quietly and do nothing
we'd rather electrocute ourselves we
always doing doing doing we are human
doings we're not human beings
anymore so if I take I I pull over the
the that I'm driving up the motorway and
I said you know what deac told me take
some time for myself so I sit in the Lor
for 15 minutes every day how is that
going to help me to
transcend it starts a process we begin
to ask
yourself who am
I I reflect on this these questions
every day who am I what do I want what
is my purpose what am I grateful for and
who am I without these cons throughout
it's it's a big mystery right who you
are ultimately you realize you're the
awareness in which all experience
happens but you're not the experience
the experience is in time you are not in
time and this requires a different kind
of education it's not part of our
culture it used to be part of cultures
you know if you read Plato and the
Republic and you'll see that you know
this was part of every
culture but it was few luminaries people
romanticize even about this in India's
spiritual country well India's been
violent forever a few luminaries the
sages of the upnishad and we have
romance around them Greek culture you
know oh Bob you know the Greeks were the
most civilized in the world well yes
Socrates and Parmenides and you know
Pythagoras and I can name a few but the
rest of the country even in those
times you know they had slavery they had
sexism they
had
these the source of the Olympics where
they used to
sacrifice humans and you know we still
performing in Even in our days we're
still repeating that cycle with the what
do you call cheerleaders the the virgin
vestel of the past we haven't changed
actually much the human
brain U
evolved as did all other species in the
sabana
and we have three brains actually we
have repti let me use a handy model for
you okay this is a handy model and the
pun is
intended okay this is your cerebral
cortex where you use your intellect
right now you're using your intellect
and this part of your brain is being
activated because this is a
conversation that excites this part of
the brain If and this brain has evolved
only
4,000 let's say uh 5 million years in
evolution this brain rapidly evolved
when we learned to use
language and then we created all these
models that I mentioned if I open my
hand here you'll see my thumb that's the
emotional brain and this brain actually
is much older than this brain it's 5
million years this brain emotional brain
is 100 million years old okay so we
pretend to be creatures of rationality
but we actually bristling with emotion
and even when we make rational decisions
they're based on our
emotions okay now if I so that's my
emotional brain and where you see my
thumb that's my Reptilian Brain which is
responsible for fight flight and
actually right now in our civilization
The Reptilian Brain and the
dysfunctional emotional brain the
separate brain has created what we call
social injustice racism bigotry hatred
ecod destruction Extinction of species
poison in our food chain War terrorism
mechanized death and much more because
these three brains are not integrated
now with psychedelics or with other
experiences meditation mindfulness
metacognition Mantra meditation combined
with music and other kinds of protocols
which we have created at the Chopra
Foundation what really happens in the
brain is at many levels so one is there
is agonism of Serotonin so the normal
anti-depressants are called ssris
serotonin Inhibitors uptake Inhibitors
this actually agon creates an action at
the receptor where the effect is
enhanced of Serotonin probably other
things dopamine oxytocin opiates Etc and
there's a new peptide that has been
identified it's called anandamide the
the peptide of bliss so at a cellular
level that's what happening at a neuro
neural correlate level what's happening
is there's neurogenesis sometimes and
there's synaptogenesis which means
neurons increase in size and they start
to connect with each other so you have
to realize that your brain is created by
Evolution and your genes but it is then
sculpted by your experiences there's
this feeling of unworthiness
like I would love to have abundance but
I don't really feel worthy of thriving
can you can you talk about that a little
bit and is that really coming from our
alignment with source and soul and I am
or is that more of an ego
thing no there's a difference between
self image and self M okay self image I
I I use this expression we sacrifice
ourself for our selfie
okay so your self becomes your identity
not yourself and what is your selfie
your self image trying to do it seeks
validation it feels either inferior or
Superior and it is full of fear that's
what these people have who say I don't
deserve it they've been conition you
know somebody at a long time ago said
you're not beautiful enough or you're
not successful enough or you'll never
make it and or you'll never be such and
such and that creates what is called a
limiting belief in the mind but there
are ways to actually overcome that
limiting belief because you once you
start questioning your
beliefs you say is it really true that I
will never be president of the company
is it really true that my husband or
wife doesn't love me is it really true
that I'll never be able to lose weight
whatever your idea of what your goal is
then you can also say how sure am I if
this is true and you know the more you
reflect on this and you say you say um
what is this doing to me why why is it
limiting me and what is the opposite of
this limiting belief now this is the
basics of what people call cognitive
therapy and now there's something also
called awareness-based cognitive therapy
and there's a woman who wrote a book
called U I forget the book's name but um
she simplified this in a very nice way
um it's basically how do you overcome
limiting beliefs and you do that through
reflective inquiry you do that by
mindfulness meditation but you also do
that by going beyond the thought process
because it's thoughts that are limiting
us if you go in meditation you know in
the cabala and all these great amazing
mystical Traditions that's the realm
that they call inol or you know the Budd
the Buddhist call it the dhak once
you're at
that understanding that that's what you
just used eino is um a source is the is
the thehere if you want to call it not
the new sphere the new spere is the mind
the thehere is the realm of the Soul or
if you don't like the word Soul
fundamental identity how you age is a
choice so you know I'm 71 and a half
right now but biologically I feel like
I'm 35 or less you feel 35 or less less
and I have the mental and physical
capacity of somebody like that be a
little more specific what do you mean
you feel like you're 35 or less if you
measure my blood pressure my heart rate
my immune system my hormone levels my
biological age would be much Le less
than my chronological age so you know
when you look at aging there's
biological age which you can measure
through cholesterol HDL ratios blood
pressure immune function hormones fat
content skin thickness bone density
aerobic capacity sugar metabolism these
are the the ways you measure biological
age then there's chronological age the
date you were born that's your
chronological my chronological age is 71
plus but biologically I'm not there yet
okay and then there's psychological age
which means how do you feel do you feel
young do you feel old Etc so aging is a
very complex phenomenon and in humans
it's not something that's so fixed in
the last century for example only 100
years ago the average lifespan of a
human being in this country was 49 years
100 years ago so 1918 yeah about the
average I'm talking about the average
okay of course there are always people
who live long today the fastest growing
segment of the American population is
over the age of 90 and close to 100 that
means the rate of growth of the
population the average rate of growth is
much bigger as I said the fastest
growing segment of the American
population is over the age of 90 as a
prop which means a kid born today is
probably going to live to 120 years old
let's just say that's not 90 years old
people are people are predicting that
when you uh go past your ego
identity there's a bigger identity that
is uh so huge it's incomprehensible it
can't even be described and there's a
freedom and a joy that comes from that
and uh I had had glimpses of that but
this period of intense Stillness and by
the way since then I've kept a week of
Silence every year sometimes I do more
and uh that week of Silence usually in
September I do every year just to go
back to the taste of Timeless being
instead of you know our ego identity
which we keep polishing every day now
especially these days with social media
and books and promotions and you name it
so apart from running out and creating a
story what can the viewers right now do
today or tomorrow to make themselves
better leaders first ask yourself those
questions that I mentioned who am I what
do I want what kind of team do I want to
have what's my role in it what are my
skills and strengths what are the skills
and the strengths of the people that I
want to have in my team you see if
people are not being fully um expressive
in their unique strengths they lose
selfesteem if they're not having fun I
am also a senior scientist at Gallup
organization and we find that only 20%
of people in this country are engaged in
what they do about 15 to 20% are
actively disengaged they come to work
unhappy and they make it a point of
making other people unhappy happy and
the rest kind of P are punching in the
clock this costs our economy of
something like $380 billion a year so
what makes uh a fun invigorating
productive environment well if your
supervisor in manager ignores you your
rate of disengagement goes up by
45% if the supervisor or manager doesn't
ignore you but criticizes you your rate
of Engagement drops to 20% you would
rather be criticized because you're now
being noticed on the other hand if your
manager notices single strength that you
have your rate of disengagement Falls to
less than 1% this has huge economic
implications each of us is born as an
infinitely creative being as children we
use our Rich imaginations to create
entire worlds whether we were building
sand castles at the beach playing house
with a collection of dolls or pretending
to be our favorite
superhero but as we become adults many
of us succumb to the prevailing cultural
meme or belief that the older we get our
brains lose their capacity to expand
adapt transform and evolve but it's a
lie as numerous Studies have discovered
the brain has a quality referred to as
plasticity the ability to form new
neural Pathways even into very old age
the brain is fluid flexible and
Incredibly adaptable to new experiences
neural plasticity is what allows us to
teach ourselves in new language learn to
play the piano play a new sport or learn
the latest dance move although you may
no longer think of yourself as a
creative or imaginative person your very
existence is evidence of your innate
creative ity in every moment you are
co-creating your reality through your
thoughts your intentions your words and
your actions we all have unlimited
creative potential because our essential
nature is pure Consciousness by learning
to reawaken your creativity you will
recapture the natural enthusiasm energy
and wonder of Youth as the ancient Vic
sages of India observed The Secret of
immortality is infinite flexibility and
creativity a victim of conditioning
means that your habitual patterns of
behavior and thinking are um a result of
the
collective uh psyche and what we call
normal in the collective psyche is
actually the Psychopathology of the
average dull ordinary
mundan um always looking for fulfillment
on something outside if I had the right
job I had the right money if I had the
right relationship had whatever the
right thing then I'd be a happy person
well it's the other way around if you're
happy you'll have the right job you'll
have the right money you'll have the
right success you'll make the right
choices for your health and you'll have
the right relationships I think there's
a better way to achieve success you know
the
success if it cost so much and you end
up having a heart attack and then what's
the point or you get up
get sick what's the point or you age
prematurely or you die what's the point
in my view
success uh should come
effortlessly uh it has come effortlessly
to me you know when you know what your
purpose in life is when you know what
you want when you have U goals that are
worthy so I define success as the
progressive realization of worthy goals
combined with the ability to love have
compassion but most importantly to not
be overshadowed by the melodrama that's
around you there's too much melodrama
you know whether it's fake news or real
news it's all melodrama the more drama
there is uh the better itself even the
genetic mistakes that are associated
with disease depends on how you live
your life and very simple things like
sleep meditation and Stress Management
movement yoga and pranayam now yoga and
pranayam goes Way Beyond exercise
because with yoga and pranayam there's a
particular nerve in the body called the
vus nerve it's the 10th nerve and the
word vus is a Latin word but it's
related to the English word Vagabond so
this nerve comes from the
midbrain it influences your facial
expression so you can now do micro
expressions and see if a person is happy
or not it influences the um eye
movements it influences the tone of your
voice are you threatened are you
stressed are you friendly are you happy
it influences your heart rate activity
then it pierces the diaphragm and it
influences the activity of every
other branch of the vus nerve that goes
to all the organs in the body so when I
discovered this through yoga teachers
and Masters I realized that the
yogasanas you know we say yog Asa
and people usually translate that into
as postures but actually the word asna
means seat as you know seat of awareness
seat of Consciousness so each yog ASA is
a particular seat of Consciousness that
stimulates a particular nerve that is
going to a organ in your body and the
only reason for that nerve is
self-regulation or healing or
homeostasis so when I discovered that I
became fanatic about yoga I haven't
missed yoga now for as long as I can
remember not one day wow okay not one
day of yoga or meditation or um or
pranayam three things our audience can
do
today to focus on their well-being if we
can leave them with a message three
things number one don't take yourself
seriously which means don't seek
validation
approval be the number two be the change
you want to see in the world and
so it is Joy always cultivate joyful
energetic body loving compassionate
heart clear mind light and sick being
and number three spend time and play and
laughter because if you're if you don't
have time to play and
laugh you R to the to know yourself you
must first inquire
into what you are not ask yourself am I
the changing body that I only know as an
intermittent stream of Sensations and
perceptions am I the changing mind that
I only know as fluctuating
thoughts and
emotions am I the evolving
personality that moves into expanded
states of consciousness
over time or am I the formless
being that knows
itself in these shifting modes of
knowing and experience that I call mind
body and
universe ask and you will receive the
answer when you put together you know
yoga movement sleep Stress
Management healthy relationships and
emotions like love compassion Joy
equinity uh food that doesn't kill your
microbiome which is the 2 million extra
genes in our body which are not human so
you only have 25,000 human genes but you
have 2 million bacterial genes in your
body this is called the microbial
microbiome it is much it's as important
as the human genome so you can change
the activity of your microbial genes
just by changing your diet so if you go
um not even vegan but if you go maximum
diversity on plant-based foods and foods
that are not contaminated with
antibiotics or hormones
or
insecticides um you can change your
genetic activity wow and the population
of your genes in less than 6 weeks and
which means then you're Reinventing Your
Body because your body is spelled out by
your genes so this got me going strongly
into how do we meant our bodies by
resurrecting our souls and going past
our minds and that's what I'm obsessed
with now harboring resentments
grievances having the need uh
to get Vengeance over a perceived uh
uh perceived traumatic experience or a
perceived
Injustice all of that
interferes with our experience of Peace
So Many have said that forgiveness is
essential for achieving true
peace so you forgive not
only
because you might shift in perspective
you forgive not because you think the
other
person deserves forgiveness you forgive
because you deserve
Peace So forgiveness is a
process uh not a onetime
event and forgiveness is a gift that we
can give to
ourselves to forgive to forgive others
we should start by acknowledging our own
pain and anger we should also try to
understand the other person's
perspective any situation can be seen
from your
perspective from the perspective of the
other and from a third party perspective
as
well and it is important to remember
that forgiveness is not about forgetting
it is about accepting what happened in
the past and moving
on ultimately forgiveness is an act of
power what are some of the key practices
and techniques that we can learn from
you that we could cultivate that kind of
Greater Consciousness to see people in
our daily
lives I would say that U once in a while
just
stop and do nothing all our problems
come from our inability to be in touch
with ourselves we're constantly running
away from
ourselves I remember when my son who's
now 47 years old and a filmmaker and an
Emmy award-winning uh director
when he was 10 I took him to India to
the Himalayas and on the highway he saw
all these people sitting he said dad
what are they doing I said nothing he
couldn't comprehend that that we could
take time sit there and do nothing so
start with that 5 minutes 10 minutes sit
there and do nothing and notice how
Restless you'll become and that's
because we always seeking the next
moment
to satisfy us when this moment is
actually perfect there's nothing wrong
with this moment and we sacrifice this
moment for the next moment and we get
there we're not present for it so I
would say start to practice a little
presentence and then get a little deeper
mindfulness practices the rest even the
genetic mistakes that are associated
with disease depends on how you live
your life and very simple things like
sleep meditation Stress Management
movement yoga and pranayam now yoga and
pranayam goes Way Beyond exercise
because with yoga and pranayam there's a
particular nerve in the body called the
vas nerve it's the 10th nerve and the
word vas is a Latin word but it's
related to the English word Vagabond so
this nerve comes from the
midbrain it influences your facial
expressions so you can now do micro
expressions and see if a person is happy
or not it influences the um eye
movements it influences the tone of your
voice are you threatened are you
stressed are you friendly are you happy
it influences your heart rate activity
then it pierces the diaphragm and it
influences the activity of every other
branch of the vagus nerve that goes to
all the organs in the body so when I
discovered this through yoga teachers
and Masters I real realiz that the yog
ASAS you know we say yog ASA and people
usually translate that into as
postures but actually the word asna
means seat as you know seat of awareness
seat of Consciousness so each yog asna
is a particular seat of Consciousness
that stimulates a particular nerve that
is going to a organ in your body and the
only reason for that nerve is
self-regulation or healing or stasis so
when I discovered that I became fanatic
about yoga I haven't missed yoga now for
as long as I can remember what else in
terms of starting your day like daily
habits so you talk about sleep as being
incredibly important here are the the
daily habits um number one is sleep now
we know by the way that lack of sleep is
the number one predictor of premature
death from cardiovascular disease lack
of sleep is also predictor of
Alzheimer's lack of sleep interferes
with your creativity lack of sleep
causes inflammation so that's for
sure number one number two U I think is
uh any practice that quietens the Mind
meditation reflection
contemplation sitting quietly watching
your breath ETC number three is exercise
number four is Mind Body coordination as
in that's different than regular
exercise you yoga practice practice and
martial arts breathing practices Tai Chi
chiong they actually activate a
different part of your nervous system
which is the parasympathetic nervous
system which causes self-regulation in
the body so it's not just exercise it's
you know something that puts mind and
body together even gymnastics or um
things like Judo and I mentioned martial
arts but yoga is my
practice uh then emotionals your
emotional and physical environment your
social environment because we live as
social beings so you know if you're if
you're have toxic relationships it's
going to cause physical
toxicity um then nutrition we now know
that you know that food that causes
inflammation refined manufactured
processed food with chemicals
antibiotics hormones insecticides
pesticides it's poison it's like putting
poison putting Agent Orange in your body
so organic food farm to table maximum
diversity of plant-based Foods now we
know a lot about micronutrients we know
about biological rhythms But ultimately
I think spiritual experience is very
important because no matter what you do
no matter what you do no matter how
healthy you are there is old age there
is infirmity and there is death so
unless you face those right
headon when you're healthy not when
you're in a crisis not when somebody
dies in your family then everybody
panics in the Riga 9th and 10th
mandelas there are hymns devoted to a
psychedelic called
s so these practices have existed since
anient ancient times what they do is
they take you beyond the dark alleys and
the ghost fill
attics and the secret passages of your
mind which bamboozles you into thinking
this is reality this is not reality this
is a projection of reality reality is
infinite possibilities infinite
creativity infinite correlation
synchronicity unpredictability
self-regulation self Evolution and
and amazing
imagination so by
loosening the neural correlates of the
collective
mind which exist in our brain and
loosening the neural correlates of the
ego mind which is called the default
mode
Network or what you know Aldis Huxley
called the reducing valve you enter a
totally different domain of awareness
you lose your fear of death you
understand your Universal nature and you
have the spontaneous emergence of what
we call platonic values truth goodness
Beauty Harmony love compassion joy
equinity and if you're lucky lose the
fear of death because you realize that
your fundamental reality is not in
SpaceTime it is without cause it is
spaceless dimensionless and infinite
Dimensions at the same time it is
timeless it is
irreducible it is fundamental it is
formless and it is infinite and it is
you the self of the individual is the
self of the universe there's no better
gift we can get to discover who we are
because once you find out who we are as
roomi said by God when you find yourself
you'll be the idol of yourself that's
how they work if you keep up with the
literature the scientific research on
self-regulation healing and
homeostasis then you've probably
heard of the vus
nerve the vus nerve is part of the
parasympathetic nervous system and it's
the longest and most important nerve in
the parasympathetic nerve nervous
system it controls uh many involuntary
functions including heart rate breathing
digestion and immune
response so the vus nerve has been
considered uh the healing nerve of the
body the sympathetic nervous system is
responsible for the fight and flight
response the parasympathetic nervous
system
for the rest
rejuvenate renew and healing response
these are part of our autonomic nervous
system the vagus nerve is the longest
nerve in our body it travels from the
midbrain and in turn is influenced by
eye movements because it interacts with
the ocular mot nerve it influences and
is influenced by facial
muscles it influences and is is
influenced by tone of
voice it influences and is influenced by
Breathing by heart rate variability in
influences and is
influenced and it is also the nerve that
goes through the diaphragm interacts
with all the hollow organs of the body
all the solid organs of the body and uh
ultimately all also influences the
activity of the
microbiome um bringing it to
self-regulation and removing
inflammation or disbiosis the vus nerve
has bilateral
traffic
so we can activate healing um by vagal
activation actually ask
yourself am I having
Joy I found that our whole focus is on
Stress Management because it is the
biggest problem stress is the number one
pandemic but is our life and our
Evolution such that work is the most
important thing do we want to go to to
our death ultimately saying I had a lot
of successful exits made a lot of money
but I never experienced Joy if you don't
you don't have joy life is wasted so ask
yourself I ask myself every day am I
experiencing Joy am I hanging out with
people who are joyful otherwise I don't
want to be with them and are we together
making other people joyful those are the
only three criteria I use and the rest
follows so make Joy the only measure of
well-being and success think about that
Joy is the only reason we're here just
look at a child before they Bamboozled
into all these social
constructs they're joyful for no reason
and that's the way to be the past is
over it is nothing more than a memory
even though when we cling on to those
memories we experience trauma and
inflammation the
future in reality is a field of infinite
possibilities but but that field of
infinite possibilities can only be
tapped in this present moment when we
dwell on the past or worry about the
future we are taking ourselves out of
the present moment and this can lead to
feelings of stress anxiety
unhappiness
so how do we realize the benefits of
living in the now when we are present in
the moment we are more likely to
experience joy peace and love we are
also more likely to be productive and
successful so lots of things that you
can do to stay in the present moment one
simple thing you can do is be aware of
your breath focus on your breath when
you're feeling ex stressed or anxious
take a few deep breaths and focus on
just the sensation of
breath another thing is to pay attention
to your
senses what do you see hear smell taste
and feel focusing on your sensory
experience can help you to become more
grounded in the present
moment I also suggest mindfulness as a
very practical way to be present
metacognition be aware of the present
moment the experience in the present
moment as it's happening without
judgment observe yourself without
judgment as Krishna morti said the
highest intelligence is to be aware of
your own self to observe yourself
without judgment so meditation yoga all
help the past and future are Illusions
although they can affect us by clinging
on to that they can affect us in the
present moment
biologically and uh there are many
benefits of being present the present
moment is all we have by living in the
now we can experience the fullness and
richness of Life the question that was
asked was how do we maximize the use of
our time here's my answer and I learned
this from Dr Daniel seagull a US UCLA
psychotherapist he says divide the time
in 24 hours into the following sections
so sleep time meditation time exercise
time relationship time down time
creative and play time focused work time
and when you eat and when you're doing
each of these things then just do those
things don't do anything else I thought
that was very brilliant and I've been
doing this now for a number of years I
sleep at least 6 to 8 hours a day I
meditate early in the morning uh for
about 1 and 1 half hours I go to the gym
after that I walk between 5 to 10 miles
a day uh I work from about 9:00 to 12:
noon then I take a full hour for a
mindful
lunch uh I take a 20 minute walk after
lunch then I start working again in the
afternoon around uh you know 1:00 or so
1:30 2 even and then I do a short
meditation at 4:30 in the evening 5:00
and I have an early supper around 6:00
and I'm in bed by about 10: now when I'm
doing this daily routine then I feel
that my rhythms are in order they're
connected to the rhythms of the
cosmos and uh when I'm uh speaking to
someone I'm present with them I don't
check my iPhone or my handheld device at
the same time because the cortical brain
can only do one thing at a time so of
course the autonomic nous system can do
many things at a time uh do one thing do
it mindfully and do it well pursue
excellence and ignore success stay
detached and divide your time into those
quadrants if you talk to great leaders
and this is well done research even by
Jim Collins if you read his book um he
says that every leader in the end says
one of the following things I was
lucky or I happened to be in the right
place at the right time there were a lot
of meaningful coincidences now if they
happen to be spiritual or religious they
may use expressions like God was on my
side I seem to be
guided um there was a state of grace at
times I was being looked after what
they're tapping into is a deeper
intelligence that goes beyond the
personal might call it transpersonal or
you know as the transpersonal
psychologists call it or you might call
it archetypal if you're familiar with
the uh teachings of kalung but what they
do is they H they have a relationship
with the
story that's what a good brand is by the
way a brand is a archetypal story it has
themes in it the good guys the bad guys
there's a little bit of intrigue there's
mystery there's
Adventure uh all the ingredients that
make a really good soap opera and they
have a relationship with that and you
know a good brand is something that
you'll buy or use the service of but
you're actually buying the story apple
is a story it's a very great story you
know and all the all the big Brands Nike
shoes it's the story of the
africanamerican urban hero you know so
when you I one of the things I tell
leaders to do is what's your story okay
can you make your story emotionally and
spiritually inspiring and you know
people will buy her story um as the
brand as the service as the product
follow your bliss does not mean get
addicted to
pleasure okay follow your bliss means
finding the core of passion and
Excellence within you it is to pursue
excellence and ignore success and if you
do that of course success will be a
byproduct but you're expressing the
highest uh potential within yourself and
when you do that you lose lose track of
time you um uh experience
ecstasy and U for when you express that
there's a need in society for that
particular expression and when Society
sees that it honors you it uh makes you
a hero a lot of people don't really
relate business and spirituality
together you don't really hear about it
how do you think it does work though do
you think you need that part I Define
spirituality as self-awareness and um
also as elements of compassion love
service honesty authenticity
Integrity I think uh even if you don't
relate to those values if you
incorporate those values your business
is going to thrive the biggest challenge
for all businesses is to restore real
business the economic meltdown was
something that happened because we had
lost uh the true true purpose of
business what's the true purpose of
business even in business school it's
not well defined you know they is the
purpose of businesses to increase
shareholder value that's a ridiculous
thing the purpose of business is to uh
help
uh Society to serve the needs of society
the purpose of a business is to serve
the interests of all that are considered
stakeholders that includes the community
and the larger ecosystem we created an
economy which was based on spending
money that people had not earned to buy
things that they did not need to impress
people that they did not like of the
$2.9 trillion that are circulating in
the world's markets less than 2% was
going to provide goods and services the
rest was what they call derivatives
Casino so now for the first time I think
we have the opportunity to create a
wisdom based economy that actually
serves the needs of
society if you are a businessman today
you need to totally reinvent yourself
you need to ask yourself you know what
are the wisdom based economies that I
can participate in you know the green
economies the alternative
energies the people who are planting
trees are making a lot of money these
days you know uh so you have to create
an economy that's based
on on serving the needs of people ask
yourself what's your
purpose what kind of contribution do you
want to make what creates joy and
ecstasy in you what are the two or three
skills that you have that when you're
expressing your unique talents or skills
time means nothing to you it's not work
it's Joy uh ask yourself who are your
Heroes and heroins in history in
mythology in religion because these are
archetypes that are seeking to find
expression through you and incarnate
through you ask yourself how can this
passion of mind um contribute to
relationship give meaning and purpose to
existence and you don't need to know the
answers if you live the questions then
life has an interesting way of moving
you into the
answers ladies and gentlemen we have a
living legend in the house with us today
Mr deac Chopra how you doing man
excellent how are you I'm great there's
so many things to talk about in a
limited amount of time we've got your
Fitbit partnership you've got your 9
first book Total meditation your choer
meditation app some of I see it there on
on your on your desk I guess here the
total meditation amazing where I want to
actually lead off is and for anybody who
wants your projects we're going to link
it up in the description below so guys
go check that
out I was speaking to somebody in my
community yesterday named Patricia who's
a huge fan of yours she listens to you
every morning she has your meditation on
in her ears she loves your calm soothing
voice and she starts her day every day
with a deepok Chopra meditation and I
asked her hey I'm talking to him
tomorrow if you have one question for
deep Cher what would it be and her
question was what brings you to your
place of strength and peace at the same
time what brings me to a place of
strength and
peace is I don't believe the
lies of the mind every every thought you
have is a magical lie it's an
interpretation of a perceptual
experience which is radically untrue so
for example my perception tells me the
Earth is flat nobody believes that
anymore my perception tells me that the
ground I'm sitting on is stationary and
I know it's spinning at dizzying speeds
and hurtling through space at thousands
of miles an hour my perception tells me
that I'm looking at your body but
actually I'm not it's a perceptual
activity in
myself so a while ago I decided not to
believe my mind and what I do is step
back from the mind and watch
it and I notic that there's me watching
it and what is me watching it it's
watching the body it's watching my
thoughts it's watching you it's watching
everything else so stand in front of a
mirror and the mirror reflects
everything not just you but everything
else that's happening
and if you understand that the entire
world is a
mirror of you filtered through the crazy
mind then you don't depend on the mind
you depend on the awareness of the mind
so when I see a situation whatever it is
good bad or what whatever I ask myself
who's watching and then I pay attention
to the Watcher and I stay there and it's
profoundly peaceful ful and
joyful at all times how do we make that
an intentional practice so that we don't
have our instant reaction to freak out
or stress out or um how do we go from
making it that instant reaction to an
intentional practice a lot of people say
you know I want to quieten my mind and
then they struggled in meditation but
trying to quieten the mind is a thought
so it's also the mind so you can't use
the mind to quieten the mind right all
you have to do is ask
yourself what am I aware of right now
and then
favor the awareness instead of the
experience because the experience is a
projection of the Mind awareness is
independent awareness is infinite
possibilities it's Limitless it's beyond
imagination it's in infinite it's the
real you that recycles as Body Mind
people talk about reincarnation but
reincarnation is happening every second
every thought that you have is
reincarnated thought every perception
that you have is actually a recycled
perception we just get bamboozled as
soon as we given a name so you know I
was given a name Deepak chra now that is
a symbol of who I am it's not who I am
but you know if you repeat somebody's
name enough you're David you're David
you're David then the poor kid is
screwed because he thinks he's David in
fact he's the infinite being with a name
called David so you know you're not your
name your name is a symbol of who you
are if I'm looking at a menu in a book
um and all these beautiful dishes are
there I can't eat the menu okay so we
use words as symbols and of course you
know spiritual literature says first
there was the word and the Word was with
God and God you know became the word or
whatever there's some truth in that as
soon as you use words you create form so
if I asked you what is this you say it's
a book but actually it's a color it's a
shape it's a form if a baby was looking
at this book it would be squiggles
shapes forms and colors no idea that
this is a book and the baby is called
David no idea it's a joyful experience
because the baby would see this and
everything else as itself and would fall
in fact is in love with existence all
you have to look at is a baby the only
time it says is when it's hungry or it's
wet otherwise it's in Bliss and why is
it in Bliss because it hasn't being
Bamboozled by
constructs and is that ultimately your
mission is to guide people towards
Bliss yes if people could understand the
magnificence of who they are that the
fundamental state is bliss and joy and
awareness and existence which is
timeless see the body is in time the
mind is in time every thought is in time
every perception is in time every image
you have in your mind is in time except
you the one that's awareness so once you
get to that this is what is called the
spiritual experience it's also actually
the original religious experience
whether it's Jesus or muham the Buddha
doesn't matter the religious experience
is just three things first you know
yourself Beyond body and mind second you
have the emergence of platonic truth
which is goodness Harmony peace um
empathy compassion love kindness joy and
the third religious experience not
religion I'm not talking about religious
Dogma religious experience loss of the
fear of death if you have those three
things you know your true self you have
the emergence of what we call platonic
values truth goodness Beauty Harmony
love compassion joy equinity and you
lose the fear of death what's left
you're
free so along those lines I was watching
a video of yours recently called total
happiness now and you had this line that
I had to pause on and you said
almost everybody gets some infirmity I'm
planning not to and I didn't know what
infirmity meant so I had to pause the
video and go look it up and it said the
least of dictionary was physical or
mental
weakness how do we live a life with zero
physical or mental
weakness you see it's almost like the
world is
so fooled
by insanity
it's not a measure of Sanity to adjust
to or become used to
Insanity right now when I look at the
world I see Insanity climate
change mass migrations with
epidemics racism bigotry hatred
Prejudice power mongering influence
pedling Extinction of species nuclear
weapons other ways of mechanized death
uh poison in the food
chain I think that's insanity if you
don't think it's Insanity then you're
declaring your own Insanity so I it's
okay to
be sane even if you're the only one in
the world okay it's okay to be S so
right now everybody says you know as you
grow old you get infirm you get
decrepitude you might get Alzheimer's
you might lose mental capacity you
probably get diabetes disase cancer
heart disease why do we say that um
because it seems everybody does okay so
we say that's the norm but everybody
accepts climate change right now almost
everybody accepts War ex everybody
accepts terrorism everybody accepts is
fine to use mechanized death to kill
people and other
species is that true is that how it
should be so I come from a tradition by
the way wisdom traditions where there's
a thing called Maha samadi Maha means
big samadi means the big meditation when
you choose you say okay been there done
that I had a great life my father did
that by the way my father was a
cardiologist trained in England so at
the end of his life he said I had a
great Innings uh you know he used to
play cricket said I had a great innings
it's over so I'm going to say goodbye
and then he closed his eyes and you know
he actually went to the room where my
mother was sleeping said goodbye to her
went back to his room sat in bed closed
his eyes and he was gone now yeah he
probably had a cardiac arhythmia or
something there has to be something that
causes the
final exit right but as far as I'm
concerned he died in
peace and in contentment and without
fear that is called Maha samadi it's a
tradition amongst my gurus going back
thousands of years and so of course they
don't talk about it they they're you
know they don't they don't care what the
world thinks of them they're not on
Twitter or Instagram or doing YouTube
videos they're happy and you know I get
that I get that I'm 74 right now my
blood pressure is 100 and 10 over 70 my
cholesterol is younger than better than
anybody who 40 years of age my heart
rate parability says I have no stress I
enjoy every day A Joyful energetic body
love and compassion in my heart clear
mind and lightness of being if you have
those four things there's nothing else
you want everything else is like crumbs
you know like what do you call it
dessert a little bit cherry on the on
the top of the cake the reality is Joy
at all times how do you know when you're
ready for that final meditation I mean I
look at you someone who's happy and
content and en joy and uh in health and
yet also still very much Mission driven
and so many exciting projects and 91
books and all these things you're still
working on how do you know when you're
ready for that final meditation
Everything I Do by the way like books
and everything talking to you is um is
to help people understand that they have
this magnificence and Bliss within them
so I'm not Mission driven I I just shoot
the breeze you know and people seem to
enjoy it so I shoot some more it it's
like somebody singing in the bathroom
people are liking the song so you oh
somebody is liking the song you sing
more that's it I'm not Bishop driven I
think hard work exacting plants driving
ambition
and you know focusing on goals all the
time is The Refuge of the failure um I
think if you have joy everything
spontaneously helps you and actually if
you're not thinking of yourself you
thinking about others everybody helps
you too so you know they come along and
they say hi how can I help you I love it
it's a it's a big mind twist at least
for a typical kind of North American
perspective audience and so um you know
thank you for sharing that here on my
channel uh let's let's move that towards
the Fitbit partnership because I think
it all ties nicely together so I love
Fitbit I I'm I've been a a customer for
years I was wearing one I just took a
show so I took it off but yes you watch
this is just a a step tracker where I
try to get 20 to 40,000 steps a day been
using this for years and I was so
excited to see deac choa is partnering
with Fitbit this is crazy and so at
least my understanding of it they've got
the watch that then can track all sorts
of vitals but including your stress
levels and so then what happens if if my
watch says hey Evan you're stressed out
right now I get an alert that then says
do a deepok Chopra breathing routine or
say this Mantra or like how how does
that how do we go from stressed out on
my watch to you entering the picture so
I would rather that you not get an alert
because that means I'm interfering with
uh you know your lifestyle or whatever
if you want to make a change then you
decide to make the change now what can
what the Fitbit does is it gives you
your heart rate variability gives you
oxygen saturation electrodermal activity
breathing rate core body temperature in
other words in real time you have
Biometrics right there on your wrist
then you have
33 mindfulness intervention or breathing
interventions or other insights from me
Deepak not me the guy called Deepak
and then you can use those to actually
in real time change your metrics now
that's called bio
regulation okay biof feedback has been
there for a long time you know people do
biof feedback through Electro andrs
through cardiac variability Etc but
bioregulation means not only are getting
feedback but you can
regulate your mind and your body and
they're the same thing by the way body
and mind is one unit like mass
and and energy like wave and particle
like actuality and potentiality like
space and time it's one entity whatever
happens in the mind happens in the brain
body whatever happens the brain reflects
back to the mind they're a correlated
activity for the first time now with
Fitbit by the way there's no other place
where we can do this right now it's the
first you get to bio regulate your own
biology it's crazy so nine minutes
before starting this with you I went to
post a story to my Instagram saying I'm
nervous I'm freaking out my heart's
beating fast you know I hope this
interview goes well I'm sure my Fitbit
would be freaking out to say heart rate
off the chains what what exercise would
you give somebody like
you know 15 minutes ago uh to do before
having to go do that thing that they're
nervous about so even if you sat down
quietly close your
eyes observed your breath and took an
inhalation to the count
of four pause to the count of two exhale
to the count of six your breathing rate
will come down from 14 to about 8 if you
do that for a minute just one minute if
you go a little bit beyond that once you
get comfortable with that you increase
it so breathe in to six pause to breathe
out six your brain waves will go from
beta to alpha alpha is a meditative
state but if you actually become good at
this I can take my brain waves down to
Theta which is the dream state and then
if I want I can actually take it down to
four the breathing rate with practice
slowly but comfortably that takes you to
Delta which is depressed the equivalent
of deep sleep okay and you're still
awake of course but you're rested the
equivalent of deep sleep for that one
minute so I would say take a breathing
break or just ask yourself am I aware
and then shift from the thought to the
awareness in which that thought is
happening and notice that
awareness and hang in there and you'll
be fine immediately I love it here's
another thing I call it the stop formula
St o s stands for stop T take three deep
breaths and smile from your head to your
toe everywhere your fingernails your
eyes your nose your mouth your heart
even your genital smiling and then um
observe your body feel it and then
choose the response you want at that
moment or you can even make it simpler
press the pause button pause breathe and
choose in looking at your work over the
past number of decades you've really
been at the front of helping make
meditation an everyday thing I mean in
the 80s nobody knew about meditation and
now everybody knows what meditation is
me personally I think meditation has
helped a lot with just mindfulness and
presence where I struggle with it and
maybe you've got some insight or
guidance on this is get into an altered
state where it feels like hey I've been
doing meditation for two hours but it
only feels like five minutes if I sit
down for an hour I'm present I'm mindful
I'm focused but it still feels like an
hour where am I on the meditation
Journey that I need to like make the
next
breakthrough even if it feels like an
hour if there are moments when you lose
track of time you say oh where was I you
were infinite at that moment so don't
try and
count the time that you left the arena
or the theater of SpaceTime and
causality the easier you are the more
spontaneous it'll be not in meditation
you know when somebody is having a good
time what did they say I lost track of
time when somebody falls in love there's
no time right when you fall in love with
anything even an idea time goes you fall
in love with a person with a baby for
that moment when you are feeling that
experience there's no time okay so
that's our essential nature when we are
connected with all that is so when
people say I get I meditate to get away
to plug unplug it's actually inaccurate
you get meditate to plug you don't get
meditate to get away from it all you get
in touch with it all when Solitude is
not the same thing as loneliness
loneliness comes from the fear of the
ego self Solitude is being connected to
all that exists so just make that
distinction okay and you'll see and when
you're listening to music do you think
when is this going to end okay you're
listening to a song do you ask yourself
when is the song going to end or you're
dancing or watching a ballerina do you
does she think when am I going to finish
right no because they are in
love and they've become what they're
doing so it is never a problem never a
problem
to focus or concentrate as the word is I
don't like the word concentrate gives me
a headache just thinking about it but it
is never a problem to focus on something
if you love it right okay so only do the
things that you love bringing it back to
Bliss and do what you love where does
service fit in can you just be always
blessed out in your own world and not
helping others because a lot of what
you're doing is obviously helping other
people with the books and meditation and
Fitbit and Partnerships and everything
you're doing
can you be totally blessed out in your
own world without serving others No in
fact if you think of your own world you
will
suffer okay so the G wisdom tradition
said the following three things to be
happy all the time following three
things now I'm going to use the
traditional words but then I'll explain
it to you okay so it says first is take
refuge in the Buddha Buddha is not a guy
it's expanded Consciousness okay take
refuge in a bigger picture rather than
thinking only me and
mine take
refuge in the S SAA means the community
of fellow
beings that you engage with and last is
take refuge in service or sa the word in
in srit so
service
community and shared Vision now I have
found as a doctor you know I still have
a license in Massachusetts in California
now in New York and uh Florida I'm
getting a license just to keep my
credentials but I when I had difficult
patients you know uh in the past Google
this that look at all the books
everybody knows everything right but how
do I treat this one patient I used to
get everybody who's not in my specialty
I'm an internist
endocrinologist but I used to get
generalists
gastroenterologists oncologist all
together in the room say shared Vision
we want to cure this patient emotional
bonding we all care about this patient
together complimenting strengths let's
give our each of us our opinion or
what's the best treatment soon we had a
solution okay and I realized this is
actually the future which we call
emergence shared Vision emotional and
spiritual bonding complimenting each
other's strengths holding each other's
back and service and you're all set I
love it well listen I took a quick look
at the clock and realized we've been
talking we're almost at our time but
it's only felt like five minutes so
thank you for this
meditation uh guys total meditation is a
book his 91st book we'll link it up
below Fitbit partnership we'll link that
up in in the the choper meditation app
as well deepo again thank you for the
time for for anybody who just a final
message who are trying to find their
Bliss who resonant with what you're
saying what would you leave them
with don't take yourself too seriously
okay just enjoy laughter peace Harmony
and love remember those four words peace
Harmony love after love that's it I love
it thank you so much for Sharon for
coming on the show thank you very much
nice to be with you because you made it
this far in a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you are
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Bob Proctor motivation check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there see in 1990 Joel
Barker wrote a book it's called
paradigms he said to be able to shape
your future you have to be willing and
able to change your Paradigm now I had
no idea what a paradig was and you might
ask yourself